après bois d'arcy l'an dernier c'est au
tour de chatou d'accueillir la course au
soleil
135 km à travers les yvelines avant de
rejoindre les hauts-de-seine
un départ fictif jusqu'à saint germain
en laye et à la sortie de saint germain
en laye un départ réel pour aller sur
sur villepreux sur ben sur les mais nul
et on va les chercher toutes les toutes
les côtes qui sont qui sont qui sont
dans les yvelines dont certains
connaissent notamment la côte de l'es17
tournant on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous on va aller chercher
la coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi ses
mots ce sont des endroits qui parle et
un retour sur saint quentin en yvelines
des difficultés de circulation seront à
prévoir la course entraînera des
fermetures quatre communes saint
quentinois sont concernés villepreux
magny les hameaux voisins le bretonneux
et montigny le bretonneux 154 coureurs
seront au départ de cette première étape
une étape qui devrait sourire aux
sprinteurs l'an dernier c'était arnaud
démare qui s'était imposé